ah I'm here with alia yay okay good last
time I was Ally blend let me put stuff
in my mouth so I got Ollie here to play
a game that I think you guys are
familiar with two truths and a lie where
you tell two truths and one lie and the
other person has to guess which one of
those is the lie that makes sense yeah
I'm feeling quite confident I don't know
much about exactly so today I'm going to
learn a lot and the person that gets the
most correct gets to Instagram whatever
they want from the other person fine Wow
I felt like our videos are just like
getting to know each other yeah getting
to know ahlian grows it's just it's just
a bonding session between and then and
then it usually ends with stuff in our
mouth would you like to go first
I can go first yes right I've actually
got a lip I see you having fun
no it's all up here I used to play the
county badminton those are words okay I
was a model for a year when I was 17
okay I have size 13 feet ha I'm gonna go
I'm gonna go to size 13 feet that was
full those yeah that's false
I do yeah and I wasn't a model you
actually go as a mom I really did yeah
so even though I lost that one you
should feel very couple I just I
discussed this with my housemates in
there what no shield she'll know that
like well you can't put that one in okay
so the next one okay I have a fear of
balloons
okay I'm allergic to chocolate yeah
when I was born my head was lopsided I'm
gonna go if your balloons as the false
mud yeah that's correct
yeah hoping that that was false because
there's gonna be like and I rub my
balloon yeah my head is a little bit
lopsided I have like physio to wake me
straight again wait what do you mean
laughs that it really liked it like it
was like a little bit this way okay
that's so I have one point yes okay
right I've got so we're doing three yeah
three years I'm afraid of heights
okay I had dog pull my bike one and I
really like wanting to get it off when
I'm cycling so I cycled faster and
thought who flew up and hit me yeah I
was once arrested was taken for another
person is put in jail for a night I'm
gonna go with jail when is false
yeah so I got two points how do is dream
so my turn okay I'm gonna start up along
the same lines with the poop
um I have someone's front lawn I have in
a pool or I have [ __ ] in
room febre okay I'm trying to imagine
the scenario they come with this
situation I would say you've maybe put
in a pool is the fake one
oh no sorry sorry sorry you can't have
food on someone's law that's the fast
one yeah wrong-o one time in college I
went for a run a really long run and I
just had to go and there's nowhere to go
cuz I felt someone's front lawn dude
that had the most concealed okay in the
last two weeks I have gotten a parking
ticket hit the back of someone's car
with my car
I have showered you get parking tickets
so much in LA so I recognize correct I
know you must have showered I don't know
now you can do not show I would say you
haven't you haven't hit someone wrong I
didn't get just one parking ticket I got
two parking tickets let's make me people
guys guys vibe that's cheating so you
already lost
I already lost Bishop and I'll do the
last one whoa okay I have more than
three secret projects happening in the
works right now I'm in a very small
scene in The Fault in Our Stars I'm
webby award I say you're doing
definitely more projects than free so
that's the full story no that's just
oh yes that's no that's true you can
lower the false one is that I'm not in
the Fault in Our Stars though I wish jog
range and that was the most self-serving
one because I just wanted to let
everyone know that I'm nominated for a
Webby Award that you can go to the
website and vote for it is in the
description that means that I get to
Instagram anything I want from a Lisa
cow okay go for okay let's see what do I
want to Instagram you are not doing the
toilet are you sure oh god it's just a
toilet that says selfie hashtag no
filter anyway thanks for watching guys
make sure they go check out all his
channel because we do fun stuff over
there and it is fun and fun and fun and
he is great and he you broke a chair
before this never forget cuz I'm so fat
okay and he's looking for a modeling
agency
so get at him I don't know I really want
the dog poo story to be true yeah that
was true what it got on your bike well I
was like I was riding down the lane and
so I fit and there was dog poo on it and
I was riding quite slow so it was you
know you're sticking to the wheel isn't
it and then I went onto the road and I
was like I really need to get this dog
poo off and I don't want to like rub it
with sponges and that so I just went
really fast down the road and all these
dog poo to my face
and it was like it was just like one of
these action movies I just jumped off my
bike just went on grass was like rubbing
my face